What is it?
Hey Sam, can you hear me? Yeah. Speak a
little louder. I remember the picture
and even the voice. You hear me? Can you
hear me? Can Can you hear me now? Or
you're okay. Go ahead. Let's see how
it's It's doable. It's manageable. Okay.
Okay. Thank you. Well, um I wanted to
ask a question regarding like the new
heaven and the new earth. Is that okay?
You want to ask me a question about new
heaven, new earth? Okay. Yeah. In
Revelation, it says like the uh the
earth will pass away, but in
Ecclesiastes, it says that pass away.
Yeah. In Ecclesiastes, it says that it
will remain forever. So, problem, buddy.
So, like I'm confused. Does it mean like
it's going to be reformed or like
destroyed or what does it mean pass
away?
What does it mean pass away?
I think I think it means like destroyed
and then recreated. What does it mean to
be destroyed and recreated? What are you
recreating if it's destroyed? Like it's
like it's gone.
So then how can it be recreated if it's
gone? That means something brand
spanking new is coming in
place. What you just said is a
contradiction. If it's recreated, then
it's not gone.
Oh, okay.
Okay. 2 Corinthians 5:17 says, same
language. Therefore, if anyone is in
Christ, he's a new creation. The old
things passed away. Behold, new things
have come. So, it's the same language
here. So, what does it mean? The old
things have passed away in reference to
you that you're a new creation. It's the
same
word. You no longer exist. You're wiped
out and a new you is recreated.
No. So, what does it mean things have
passed away? Like reformed, like
changed.
The things that are now true of the
earth won't be true of it in the future,
but the earth itself will still be
standing. And here is an example. Did
you know this is the second earth? The
second world, not the first one.
Like this one currently? Yes.
No, I did not know that. No, this is the
second ear. World. It's not the first
world.
How do I know? I want you to read for
me. Second Peter 3. We're going to read
verses 1 to 10, but you start reading.
Okay. This is nonbeloved. The second
letter I am writing to you in which I am
I am stirring up your slow so we can
follow you, mister. This is nonbeloved.
The second letter I am writing to you in
which I am stirring up your sincere mind
by way of reminder that you should
remember the words spoken beforehand by
the holy prophets and the commandments
of the Lord and Savior spoken by your
apostles. Knowing this first of all that
in the last days mockers oops like in
the last days mockers will will come
with their mocking following after their
own lusts and saying where's the promise
of his coming for since the fathers fell
asleep all continues just as it was from
the beginning of creation reading or no
I I kind of do well you can't read
without understanding so what is he
saying what's going to happen before
Christ returns
that mockers will come. And why are they
going to mock?
Because um they're mocking because
Christ hasn't returned yet. Exactly. So
pay attention. Hey, it's been 2,000
years. Where's your Jesus? Haha. Right.
Yeah. Like atheists. So understand what
you're reading. Good. Keep reading.
Okay. Uh I stop. Oh yeah. For since the
fathers fell asleep, all continues just
as it was from the beginning of
creation. For when they maintain this,
it escapes their notice that by the word
of God, the heavens existed long ago and
the earth was formed out of water and by
water through which the world at that
time was destroyed.
No longer in that world.
Uh okay.
Are we in that world? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
we are. Oh, but according to you, it
says destroyed. That means that world
doesn't exist.
So that world was destroyed by what?
Keep reading. Being delorged with water,
but by his word, the present heavens and
the earth are being reserved for fire,
being kept for the day of judgment and
destruction of ungodly men. Okay. So
that world was destroyed by the flood by
water. So that world doesn't exist. It
still exists. But wait, it said
destroyed. How does it exist?
Yeah, I was wrong. Let me understand
what you're telling me, mister.
Yeah. Yeah, I was wrong. Yeah. Because
destroyed doesn't mean to be wiped out
of existence, right? Yeah.
Destroyed means the earth in its current
state will be
purged and that this earth will no
longer be characterized by the things
that has ins snared it right now. Right.
Yeah. And so that world that he
destroyed, he destroyed with water,
right? Yeah. This world he'll destroy
with what? Fire. But that world, you're
still living in it, aren't you? Mhm. But
it said it was destroyed.
The globe was wiped out. Or no, it's
saying all the bad evil elements that
was in the world was destroyed by flood.
Yeah.
And yet that world is still existing
because you're in it, right? Yep. So
what does it mean that this world will
be destroyed by fire? It's going to be
wiped out.
It's going to be destroyed but not like
completely like wiped out. Exactly. It's
not going to be wiped out. Everything
evil, everything base, everything
immoral will be wiped out. Right. Yeah.
And this is talking about the same
context
that Revelation about because it's on
about a new heaven, new earth. Keep
reading. No, you
stopped right here. You stopped at
seven. I'll keep reading.
Okay. Um, but by his word, the present
heaven and earth are being reserved for
fire, being kept for the day of judgment
and destruction of ungodly men. But do
not let this one fact escape your
notice, beloved, that when the Lord one
day is like a thousand years, and a
thousand years like one
day. The Lord is not slow about his
promises, as some consider slowness, but
he is patient towards you, not willing
for any to perish, but for all to come
to repentance. But the day of the Lord
will come like a thief in which the
heavens will pass away with a roar and
the elements will be destroyed. Pass
away. Huh?
Okay.
Oh yeah. And then what will happen
with intense heat and the earth and all
its works will be found out since all
since all these things will be destroyed
in this way. Oh,
heavens will roar and the elements will
be destroyed then the earth and its
works will be found out since all these
things are to be stored this way. So you
told me destroyed means wiped out
doesn't exist.
No. Yeah, I was wrong. Yeah.
What sort of people ought you to be in
holy conduct and godliness, godliness,
looking for and hastening the coming of
the day of God of the day of God because
of which the heaven burning will be
destroyed and the elements will melt
with intense heat. But according to his
promise, we are looking for new heavens
and the new earth in which righteousness
dwells. So was the world wiped out by
the flood? Yes.
Disappeared,
vanished, and a new planet was brought
into being? No. So what makes you think
that this world will be wiped out of
existence and a new world will be
brought into being? Yeah, that's my bud.
Right. So, no, that's not what it means.
And then, how can the outpouring of the
the water be the Holy Spirit when that
water destroyed the earth?
All right. Now, so you got your answer.
Yep. I did. Yeah. So, where is the
contradiction?
No. Yeah. There's no contradiction.
Ecclesiastes saying that this earth will
remain but not in its current situation
and condition. Yeah.
This is the earth that God transform and
purge so that when he does purge it,
transform it for a time. Then this will
no
longer be contaminated by evil because
there will evil
on the earth. Yeah. Right. Correct.
Yeah. So, I hope that answered your
question. Any other question? man. Um,
no. Actually, I was, this topic came up
when I was talking with my auntie. She's
a Jehovah Witness. Oh, man. You guys,
man, what are the Jehovah's Witnesses,
man? Win them. Keep answering them and
win them over. I'm, you know, by the
grace of God. Amen, bro. All right. If
that's your question, I'll move on to
the next, brother. Yep. God bless. God
bless you, guys. My connection.